Now that you know about the different
states in the activity lifecycle,
how do you tell the system that you
want to know about certain transitions?
So for example, you probably only want
to show an animation on the screen,
if the user's actively
looking at your activity.
And you want to stop that
animation as soon as the screen is
not visible anymore.
Well, similar to click handling,
the system will signal to you
that a lifecycle transition is
happening via a method callback, and
each of the transitions
gets its own callback.
So using these callbacks, it gives you,
as a developer, an opportunity to
intervene and execute statements.
So things like restoring, or saving any
data, or even cleaning up references
that you no longer need at
the moments that you need them.
So here I am in the numbers activity and
you may have noticed that we've been
writing the majority of our code in
the activities on create method.
So this is a callback that the system
executes once it has created your
activity, and thus by overriding
the method in your class definition,
you're able to specify what you
want to happen during that stage.
Also this is where we inflate
our layout XML resources,
obtain references to the view
that we want to manipulate and
initialize any other crucial objects
that our app relies on to function.
Now in the Android
developer documentation,
if we look at the activity class,
it shows all the system callbacks for
the various states of
activity lifecycle.
So you can override any of these
methods within your actively class
if you want to execute some code,
when the activity transitions
into a particular state